merci d'être avec nous c'est vendredi on
est en direct et je rappelle que touche
pas mon poste et le seul le seul talk
show et la seule émission en direct bien
sûr tous les soirs regardez c'est du
[Rires]
direct cascade 19h46 quand vous êtes
chez vous les chériis moi je suis là en
fait voilà on est moi j'aime bien le
direct parce que je jure moi quand je
regardais la télé avant j'étais plus
petit bah c'est vrai que je me disais
j'aime bien savoir que le mec pendant
que je regarde la télé bah lui il est là
tu c'est pas il est en train de faire un
pingpong tu vois ça m'énerve bah nous on
est là voilà on est là on est avec vous
on vous accompagne et on vous aime fort
et merci
d'ailleurs merci d'ailleurs d'être là
allez chéri dans un instant je vous
lirai ce tweet du professeur raou qui
m'a énormément touché j'adore le
professeur raou qui a fait un tweet je
voulais que je vous le l tout de suite
je l'adore je l'adore ce professeur raou
d'ailleurs je l'ai retweet je retweete
peu de choses mais celui-là je l'ai
retweeter professeur raou qui a écrit
hier le club des gentils vous adoris
quand je lis on est les gentils mais
quand on réussit on déchaîne la haine
des
ratés alors je sais pas c'est eu Morin
éouard Morin dit les ratés ne vous
rateront pas non c'est e Morin c'est un
Edgar
Edgar comme le café de l'gar je le
connais pas plus c'était pour rmon que
j'ai ditedard même si tu me dis Edgar ou
Edouard toi tu connais Christian Morin
la
clarinetteou de la fortune qu'on
embrasse Christian Edgar Morin station
de métro châtelé truc même pas c'est
même pas je connais toutes c'est même
pas calme-toi tu nous fais chier on va
pas s'arrêter
làdessus quel beau mot écrit du la
notoriété qu'on a pas toujours voulu
c'est mon cas par qu'il parle de lui
pasain déclenche des jalousies
imprévisibles et féroces la plus haute
distinction que l'on puisse espérer de
cet ordre est d'être insulté et diffamé
par l'émission Complément d'enquête je
suis heureux de faire partie de ce club
des insultés il estun distinction inoui
comprenant Philippe de viler qui a créé
la plus grande réussite française le
meilleur parc d'attraction du monde avec
le pu du fou avec Cyril Hanouna le plus
écouté de nos animateurs mélant humour
franchise et authenticité
oh j'ai envie de
m'arrêter je suis fier de faire partie
de cette congrégation et je dis avec
Camu qui finit dans l'étranger avec
j'espère qu'ils m'accueilleront demain
avec des cris de haine choisis ton camp
camarade la gloire ou la haine de Gaulle
disait la France ne peut-être la France
sans la la grandeur sans la grandeur
bravo
professeur j'ai reté j'ai reté ah on
s'aime bien le professeur c'est vrai
c'est il y il y a eu un truc vous avez
vu cette histoire c'est l'homme qui paye
je n'ai même pas un moyen de paiement
sur moi êtes-vous choqué par les propos
de Sarah Salman ce matin c'était dans
les grandes gueule et aller avec nous
juste après ça ça a fait débat ça tout
le monde en a parlé toute la journée
c'est parti non mais déjà c'est l'homme
qui paye toujours quelle que soit la
situation pour moi il y a pas de débat
sur la situation j'ai même pas un moyen
de paiement sur moi admettons qu'un
homme me paye pas l'addition je me
lèverai dans le restaurant j'irai en
chercher un j'iris écouter celui avec
qui je suis veut pas payer est-ce que
vous pourriez payer pour moi ou tu n'as
jamais payé une addition d'un homme
professionnellement si c'est un
rendez-vous uniquement professionnel
professionnel je suis pas pas
professionnel jamais j'ai pas de carte
bleue sur moi je n'ai pas de moyen de
paiement alors je vais te dire euh merci
Sar
S se protéger c'est gagner
l'indispensable manuel de self défense
juridique bien entendu et survie
juridique Sarah qui est avocat je le
rappelle elle est pas là pour enfiler
des perles Sarah est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec Sarah SMAN ou pas ça a
choqué ce matin tout le monde a parlé de
ça moi je suis complètement d'accord
avec toi je te le dis je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi après
chil Verdez non mais ça c'est comme
d'habitude bien s j'ai rien dit encore
c'est bon que tu le défonces ça
vraiment va parler tu le défonceras
après c'est c'est insupportable ce
canard VC vasy CAN mais c'est une honte
et ça n'a rien à voir avec la générosité
moi quand j'invite une femme je P
toujours moi qui paye avec toi de qu tu
parles m' jamais invité tu es pas choqué
alors êtesv d'accord écoutez cy au moins
il a dit ê vous
d'accordes d'accord Cho il pas
chesv choqué bien sûis choqué choé mais
c'est
une arrte
ve
mais vous avez du mal à comprendre une
question éégalité mais j'ai même pas pu
enler une l'égalité homme femm
l'indépendance des femmes vous qui
travaillez vous les réduisez à quoi à
être invité par des hommes l'homme est
un portefeuille et la femme subit ce que
l'homme veut bien lui offrir vous êtes
fol
ça all fol
allié vous avez les cheveux gras vous
tirez la chasse d'eau tous les 15 jours
alors oui vous n'avez pas les moyens de
m'inviter et toi tu prends et to tu
prendsain par jour et tu vasouler la
planète seu avec
trucs
fout aucune femme voudraitêre invité par
vous vous êtes un crassux allez vous
laver les
[Applaudissements]
cheveux
et
ça c il commence son propos dis vous
êtes folle est-ce que c'est c'est
ça prop parle pas comme ça c'est une
[Rires]
amie ces propos là sont d'un sexisme
incroyable c'est de la galanterie de la
galanterie mais la galanterie c'est
volontaire la galanterie c'est assumer
la galanterie c'est du partage vous là
vous assz ça comme si toutes les femmes
devaient subir le portefeu d'un hom ça
fait plaisir si vous êtes pas
indépendante so je avocate donc je pense
que inflenceuse on dirait vous voulez
que du buz même comment vous parlez
donné on est en 202 bah oui oui moi je
suis indépendante quand je sors je paye
pour moême moi je paye pas pour enfin si
je suis avec un homme dans un registre
de séduction je ne paye pas c'est le
c'est la galanterie alors je peut-être
un peu conservatrice c'est vrai moi
j'arrive pas les seins à l'air et
habiller en Jup courte j'enchaîne pas
les partenaires c'est vrai je parle pas
du tout vous et alors les femmes qui le
font elles ont le droit c'est c'est quoi
ce jugement
làoc moi je suis conservatrice et
j'estime qu'on doit pas donner son corps
c'est pas le débat mais on doit pas
donner son corps à tout le monde et que
c'est voilà je peut-être
tropipp mais je vous dis juste les
choses B vous non plus Sarah la
formulation elle était dans la dans la
formulation moi je suis pas choqué parce
que voilà mais enfin je je trouve que ta
formulation oui si parce que je suis
choqué je suis je ne suis pas d'accord
après on se choque très vite maintenant
ici dans dans au 21e siècle on se choque
pour tout on se cho je suis pas d'accord
avec tes propos dans la mesure où où ce
que tu dis c'est que je viens carrément
sans moyen de paiement moi je viens avec
un moyen de paiement et je suis flatter
si l'homme me propose après s'il ne me
le propose pas libre à moi ensuite de
poursuivre ou non la relation avec
l'homme mais là tu tu tu arrives en
disant c'est comme ça et pas autrement
sinon ce n'est pas un homme et c'est ça
qui est qui est gênant mais moi ça me
gêne si l'homme ne paye pas moi je suis
vraiment à l'ancienne c'est-à-dire que
l'homme paye l'addition ce qui n'empêche
que tout ce que j'ai sur moi je l'ai
payé je demande pas à me faire
entretenir me porte ma valise m'ouvre la
porte et me serre mon verre d'au c'est
peut-être très obervateur très vieux jeu
mais je suis attaché à a plein de gens
qui disent vous avez été méchante avec
Gill à mon Gill non mais Gill je l'aime
beaucoup en off et vous le savez gillah
quand on a des amis comme vous on a pas
besoin
d'ennemis me défon elle dit que je suis
dégueulasse elle dit quand même beaucoup
il dit il dit que je suis folle ve pas
de ton amitié il dit que je suis
folle non mais c'est vrai le pauvre il
est pas il est pas crasseux il s'est lav
tous les jours non les chevux sont
propresok Valérie Valérie je pense qu'en
fait faut faut la prendre au au milliè
degré moi personnellement trouve drôle
mais tout ce que tu dis à chaque fois
que ça soit sur ce sujet là ou plein
d'autres sujets à chaque fois je ne
donne aucun crédit parce que tout ce que
tu dis c'est uniquement c'est vrai pour
du buzz tu tu le sais tu dois l'assumer
non je ne paye pas l'addition ça c'est
ouais mais que tu dis que tu viens sans
carte bleue à chaque fois c'est pour la
provocation et parfois d'ailleurs c'est
sur des sujets qui sont très touchy tu
aimes provoquer parce que tu as envie
qu'on parle de toi tu as envie de la
lumière et c'est ton seul M vous êtes
tous un peu comme ça autour de ce
plateau non non non parce que souvent on
dit des choses qu'on pense vraiment non
toi je pense que tu u jamais pris un ver
ensemble toujours une une façon de faire
qui dont tu sais que ça va choquer les
gens parce que c'est ton se et bien je
ne trouve ça pas choquant de vouloir
quand j'arrive sur tous les sujets je
parle de toi en règle générale et bien
tous les sujets je les ai pensé alors et
je les ai assumé je suis jamais arrivé
ici sur ce plateau en disant non je
retire JeanMichel mer moi ça me choque
pas du tout je suis désolé Gill mais
enfin on peut très bien respecter les
femmes et être pour l'égalité
hommesfemme tout en gardant un côté un
peu vieux jeu ouvrir la porte de la
voiture aux femmes leur offrir des
fleurs payer au restaurant pas être
choqué quand elle se maquille voilà moi
c'est un truc qui me voilà je suis un
peu l'ancienne génération mais je suis
comme
ça et quand une femme veut participer
j'insiste pour que non elle garde
vraiment tu es choqué je suis choqué
parce qu'il y a tout un côté avec Sarah
il y a tout un côté princesse il faut
qu'il me tienne la porte faut qu'il
porte ma valise il faut qu'il me ramène
chez moi avec la voiture faut qu'il paye
le restaurant il faut ceci il faut cela
on a l'impression que c'est c'est un
autre monde mais on a l'impression que
c'est c'est trs
ch elle me
décrit oui oui mais oui mais parce que
peut-être que toi tu peux le faire mais
il y en a d'autres il peuvent pas le
faire comme ça porter valiser
chercher a qui peuvent pas tous le faire
on pas pas on pas envie d'ê ça et le
pire c'est qu'elle te dit j'ai pas de
moyen de paiement j'ai pas de carte
bleue j'ai vraiment quelque chose à dire
de façon officielle Ron tu aurais dû te
taire et là je vais dire devant 2
millions de
téléspectateurs ça fait 6 mois que tu me
dis Sarah c'est quand qu'on va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dînery vasy martoiend fini fin et quand
tu don une date non non parce que je
vais finir r tuas pas les reins pour
payer mon verre à 12 € rit c'est ça la
réalité passe pas 12 € passe
pas
vousz pire non pire il donne une date la
veille la veille il trouve un mytho mais
pas un mytho
genre le mensonge qui sent la défaite et
la loose att attendez les gars là les
gars attendez attendss minutes parce que
là
attends
attends Mo non attends on va tout
prendre depuis le début on arrête tout
on casse le débat s'il plaît 19 directec
on prend tout depuis
depuis le
début vas-y raconte-moi alors qu'est-ce
alors raconte-moi depuis le
début vous êtes écrit transpire qui m'
ou non mais c tu vas t'assir après de
moiens non non je vais prendre des kinex
pour Ron
[Rires]
parcei
t un jour avait demandé quel était son
mec préféréa dit oui mais il il a il a
bien compris ah ou alors
àô j'étais chez Jordan de luxe on
demande mon chronque
alors m'envoie un
texto s'il te PLA laisse version laisse
sa version laisse sa
versionasy vasy vas-y alors oui il me
dit on se voit bientôt mais moi j'ai dit
ça
oui anné tu veux que je vous mon
téléphoneout on est pas là pour faire
voir
[Applaudissements]
les tout le monde commence à regarder
les téléphones de ça a même commencé des
juin donc ça là on est en juin juillet
pendant les vac 2023 ou tu veux que je
sor c'est étonnant non mais je te donne
la confi changé de
VO monte dans les AIG alors en juillet
Ramon m'appelle il me dit ouais je suis
je suis dans le sud si tu veux qu'on se
voit bon mais non là il y a
avoc je pas appelé pour ça non mais ou
c'est vrai il truc à la fin non non je
t'ai pas appelé pour un pote qui
divorçait qui cherchait un avocat au ça
je diraai rien là-dessus c'est le secret
professionnel j' quand même
un truc mais je te donne la phrase de
conclusion si tu veux nous rejoindre
c'est quoi la phrase de si tu veux
nous je pas il est pas il
pasite septembre alors septembre là là
tu brasses de l'air en septembre c'est
extordinaire s'il vous plaît sil vous
plaît calme-toi calmei aprs
tu
cour moi je fais une m
dans truc c'est que j'ai des preuves
donc c'est M pas
alors vas-y alors vas-y septembre est-ce
qu'on peut se voir la semaine prochaine
qui qui demande ça moi toi oui oui oui
c'est pas toi tu veux que non mais
arrête avec ton
téléphoneuept on a on a une date Val un
soir une date pas de lieu célibataire
toi au moment du truc je le suis pas ah
d'accord mais ça veut dire que
maintenant ça l'empêche pas ça le mais
lui non plus il est pas célibataire et
il me dit pas qu'il il me dit qu'il a
quelqu'un amicalement mais tout à fait
c'est pas
mal il non non mais il a eu peur
conneries toi je suis clean il est cle
et ensuite la veille il trou te défendre
non c'est pas toi c'est lui que je non
non il a été très correct il m'a dit
qu'il avait quelqu'un et ensuite il me
lâche il me laisse en remis peut-être je
sais pas bien 8h il revient avec une
excuse mais bidon c'està-dire l'excuse
elle est là tu je va rien tu veux
vraiment que dis tu veux vraiment que je
dise ah non mais il me dit Disle non non
non Disle pas c'est quo
vasy l'événement que tu avais c'est quoi
c'est quoi l'excuse dans le votre
oreille d'abord avant
répète dit avec un smiley quand même je
m'en souviens je l'ai regardé avant de
venir quoi l'oire un gala dans le 12e
est-ce que tu veux venir avec moi un
gala dans le 12e moi je fais pas de gala
moi il est chanteur de charme lui donc
là je me dis et c'est là et c'est là où
j'en viens au au propos terminologique
peut-être que tu ne voulais pas c'est là
tranquille si elle veut se faire inviter
par un homme c'est son problème laiss
tranquille propos terminolog jamais vu
qu'il voulait pas payer d'où
l'invitation au Gala mais après il vous
a relancé ou pas non il a conclu comment
le ça s'est conclu comment il m'a lâché
une vue ah ouais mais il la ramène moins
là il y a les autres je suis pas tout
seul
moi chape de plomb sur ce plate on
t'écoute en vrai
alors en vrai on sa c'est vrai qu'on
s'est parlé en texto c'est vrai qu'on a
dit qu'on irait boire un verre j'ai même
dit si tu veux on va dîner en vrai le
déclencheur c'est un ami qui divorce ça
c'est pas des conneries c'est Jordan de
luxe le déclencheur dans l'émission B
oui parce qu'elle c'est parce qu'elle a
dit bien parce que c'est après mon ami
qui a
divorcé la première fois que tu prends
contact avec Jordan le admettons que
c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
Jordan
je suis atterré vous saviez pas vous
savez tout de votre amie alors moi je
vous jour que je savais pas non il m'a
pas dit ça tu sais qu' ah non je sais
pas il m'a dit pas tout donc vous tombez
vous tombez de haut là mais non mais
c'est pas de haut c'est incroyable vous
Géraldine vous le saviez ah non pas
personne SAV personne on l' dit à
personne on savait que céit char mais
mais il ne m'aurait pas il aurait pas
commencé à faire l'au fusqué comme son
confrère Gill verd j'aurais rien dit
d'accord vous avez d'autres dossiers sur
d'autres personnes ici m' parler quoi
vous tremblez tous hein non quoi tu as
d'autres dossiers vas-y bah balance tout
ce soir allez c'est pas grave non mon
Tiel en soirée très correcte ça c'est
pas la soirée du Gala où on s'est
croisé rien c'est moi qui animé la
soirée donc et bangorien euh si je veis
faire un bilan des chroniqueurs il y a
que rmon quoi des méchancetés un peu il
a que Raymon valer j'adore j'ai rien
faire les gars non mais non
mais pas ton non mais à la fin à la fin
à la fin il a rien fait à la fin il y a
que DLE à la fin il y a rien du tout on
sa pas mais quand tu dis oui aller dîner
bah nous pendant 6 mois tu as brassé de
l'air pendant 6 mois tu as quand même
beaucoup brassé de l'air
oui après il travaille beaucoup he mais
mais on devait se voir pour prendre un
verre après tu peux venir avec ton
camion de livraison quand tu es proche
TFEL et on on mangera un kebab dans ton
camion il y a une complicité il y a
quelque chose qui se passe quand même il
y a encore B en plus maintenant
bah complicated en fin de course ah
ouais à cause du Ray non non non
non bon il y a pas d'autres chroniqueur
mais non mais le qui a faillli prendre
un ver avec elle c'est toi oui même
dîner j'ai même dit même dîner j'ai même
dit viens on va dîner je crois que même
un weekend même un weekend sur la riv
aprèsémission à quelle fin en fait vous
y allez à quelle fin amicalement non non
c amicalement amicalement non vraiment
vraiment amicalement voir plus il
affinité ah oui mais non si toujours
dîner faut pas arrêter
célibata parce que toi tu es un sauvage
tu peux aller dîner et partir et rentr
femme j'ofre les
fleursle je ti
pas intéressé il y aurait rien eu non
mais non mais on peut aller aussi dîner
avec quelqu'un sans AR s on aller boire
un ver donc là c'était vraiment tout
bien tout honneur la grande question
c'est qu'est-ce que vous lui trouvez
comme charme c'est
quoi c'est parce que je vous ai pas
désigné non pas du tout non non
contraire ça m'intéresse il plaît
énormément ce que Jordan luxe m'avait
demandé c'était quel quel chroniqueur
vous préférez et j'avais répondu
effectivement rond à bout et il m'av dit
pourquoi j'avais mis la virilité en
premier voilà et c'est pour
ça
tu as arrêé des pubs dans ton
émission mais Raymon c'est parce que tu
avais entendu ça que tu l'as contacé
c'est parce que tu avais entendu ça que
tu sur le ban des accusés he je crois
pas que c'est je sais pas c'est ça il y
a une conomittance des dates en tout cas
qui important dîner avec quelqu'un ici
serait Raymon bah maintenant je vais
peut-être changer
d'avis si ouais si tu viens la virilité
en va me faire payer il va me dire il va
me dire c'est je suis sû je suis
persuadé que vous aviez été
célibatairees tous les
deuxors je pense pas parce que je suis
trop honnêtement je suis trop princesse
ah ouais ouais Mo ouais pour moi c'est
trop princesse trop princesse ouais mais
ça ça va beaucoup trop vite je vous
Auris bien vu
ensemble sur R quand même Lady la
princesse le routi
ou non je dirais je pense être un peu
trop princesse c'est contrairement à ce
que dit Hugo manos je l'assume c'est
vrai à 12 ball je passe pas très bien le
soda à 12 balles non je passe pas le
qu'est-ce qui se passe les deux là sans
déconner c'est
incroyable cherche moi je te propose un
kebab à la tourelle en bas de chez moi
tu tu remp sur le soda kebab non mais tu
Prine kebab justement j'en ai jamais
mangé ce sera une exp prenez un verre
tous les deux de
guerre et vous savez
cy tu sais ce que je vais faire je pense
que je vais inviter Gill et c'est moi
qui vais payer ah non non parce que éé
dur avec dur B non je suis pas du tout
vexé non avec plaisir mais c'est moi qui
invite bien entendu oh il est mignon
franchementou c'est fou mais est-ce que
vous allez vraiment le faire ou faites
comme Raymon je vais
réfléchir
[Applaudissements]
excuse-moi Sarah elle veut un bail avec
tous les chroniqueurs truc de fou ça il
y a Hugo aussi hein Hugo manos il est
beau alors non non mais après j'ai j'ai
des critères un peu j' peut-être j'an il
y en a un je peux pas le dire à
l'antenne mais si vas-y je peux le dire
à l'oreille c'est quoi la virilité c'est
ça non c'est quoi non non non bah vas-y
dis B assume tuassumes tout d'habitude
ouais de quoi bon après il y a un
critère d'âge moi c'est plutôt 50 enfin
plutôt plus
âgé même milieu social et quelqu'un qui
travaille et je viens avec Laurent si tu
veux présenter Laur
R et quelqu'un et quelqu'un qui est un
travail bien quelqu'un qui a un travail
oui Jacques cardose un peu mais j'ai un
travail non nonard Jacques cardose
he on est sur du Jacques cardos les gars
on est plus sur du Jacques cardos que du
Raymond ah et pas marié évidemment ouis
B oui il est marié bon benah écoute JAC
cardos ça pourrait mais il est marié ou
alors que toi tu es pas marié tu vois
moi je suis pas marié il pas marié et j
il est pas marié non plus hein bah si je
t'emmerde je
t'emmerde c'est
quence est exceptionnelle s char non
mais je pensais que vous étiez tous au
courant en fait de quoi de quoi
quex avec est un très
secr sais je vais te dire est si on est
au courant de tous les SMS de
Ron le prochain complément d'enquête
c'est que sur
lui ce qui est étonnant c'est que vous
vous ne soyez pas au cour voulez vous
dise la vérité jecoup avec lui et il est
très secret concernant je sais même pas
où il en est je vous le jure que c'est
vrai il ne me parle pas du tout de ça ok
jamais par pur non non je sais pas
franchement on parle pas de ça on parle
tout de conneries avec CR on parle je te
jure que c'est vrai je vous jure on
parle jamais il parle jamais de ces
histoires revche il va falloir qu'il
change de tenue parce que là il
est je sens la chaleur non non non je
mais non bon écoutez en tout cas moi je
suis sûr que vous pouvez vivre une belle
histoire tous les deux et sachez je
serai là et et et et je vous soutiendrai
tous les deux dans cette
belle et bien
sûr Gilles j'ai pas voulu être
désagréable avec vous tuis pas remettre
une pièce si je vais Gill je je vous
présente mes excuses si j'étais
désagréable merci c'est mignon voilà je
les
accepte c'est que Gill il est avec Fatou
non non mais ça va ça va se finir ça
arrête alors pour le divorce je peux
vous faire un prix fa pas mari vouses
pas Mar non mais Gilles verd ça pourrait
être ton style ou pas euh
ça correspond la
le la façon enfin tout ce que vous dites
à l'antenne c'est quand même très
compliqué enfin on peut prendre sur en
fait il y a personne qui a grâce à vos
yeux ah ouais c'est dur he est paréon
c'est vrai non mais d'un point de vue
politique ou idéologique c'est un peu on
est d'accord c'est pas
rmon il y a plus du tout de pub dans
C
pu vous avez il dit il y a plus de
pub faire une histoire avec lui ah oui
je crois je pense que le mode de vie il
aurait dit mais c'est elle est trop
princesse c'est pas possible dit la
vérité je sais pas
c'est pas c'est oui non parce que je
pense que le le mil en tout cas il y a
un élan et je m'adapte moi je suis un
caméléon je
m'adapte croyez pas je metis partout moi
sil faut mettre un costard je vais
mettre un costard jeis c'est
extraordinaire ce qui se passe ce
soir ou il va il va dire elle est trop
princesse c'est pas possible les weekend
ça on s'en fout de ça quand on aime
quelqu'un on s'en fout on peut changer
par il a des clés de maison de
C et
le rien à voir franchement çaen en tout
cas vous avez été très
dark est très très très on va parler on
est là pour rigoler oui mais calmez-vous
quand
même vous avez autre chose à rajouter
est-ce que avez un un un gars voilà si
si vous dit tout de suite vous dites oui
tout de suite oui mais je vais rien dire
à l'antenne vous connais oui mais non au
moins l'oreille de Cyr non non ça va
être encore pire il va le répéter tout
non non non c'est bon je pense qu'on va
on va
Saras je te jure je comédien chanteur je
dis pas qu'il est connu connuoui oui il
est connu il est connu on le connaît
nous bah dans quel domaine est connu
est-ce qu'il est déjà venu il est au
gouvernement non ben non non non
comédien non chanteur avocat c'est Jean
Lalle chanteur attends
chanteur mais en réalité il est vrai que
j'ai que trois relations et général mais
c'est pas beaucoup mais bon c'est comme
ça avec rmon non pas avec rmon et euh
c'est vrai que c'était des personnalités
publiques ah Ouaiss faut qu'il soit
connu en plus non pas bah ça c'est pas
ça s'est joué comme ça moi je je ne peux
pas officialiser tant que je suis pas s
d'avoir un mariage par contre les gens
connus ont un zizi avec les lunettes de
soleil quoi qui reconnaisse non c'est
que des mecs connus en tout cas forte
notoriété forte notoriété important ça
il faut que la personne soit connue non
c'est pas obligatoire elle est
incroyable cette émission je vous dis la
vérité je m'attendais pas du tout à ça
j'ai l'imession mais j'ai peur de
rallumer mon téléphone en sortant parce
qu'en fait ma relation actuelle n'est
pas totalement finie donc mais bah là je
peux vous confirmer qu'elle est
finie on va serouver dans un instant
tout de
suite